>> Sean: WELCOME BACK TO THE
SPECIAL EDITION OF HANNITY.
BOOMERANG OF JUSTICE AS WE
REVEALED DAYS AGO, THE REPORT IS
DELAYED.
TWO MAJOR DEVELOPMENTS.
KEY WITH ITS LAST MINUTE HAVE
DECIDED TO COOPERATE OTHERS
COMING BACK TO ADD TO THEIR
TESTIMONY.
AND CHRISTOPHER STEELE, THE ONE
THAT CREATED THE DIRTY CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR RUSSIAN
DOSSIER FULL OF LIES, HE WAS
GRILLED BY D.O.J. INVESTIGATORS.
THE DEEP STATE ABUSE OF POWER
SCANDAL, FINALLY COMING FULL
CIRCLE.
HERE TO SMAN MORE, FORMER
CONGRESSMAN AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR TREY GOWDY.
YOU WERE A PROSECUTOR, NEVER
LOST A CASE, I RESPECT THAT
ABOUT YOU, I MENTION IT A LOT.
MULE HEARS LOT OF EXPLAINING TO
DO AS KEN STARR SAID.
AND AS OUR PANEL HAS BEEN
POINTING OUT.
IF YOU, TREY GOWDY, WERE ON THAT
COMMITTEE WHAT WOULD YOU WANT TO
KNOW?
>> WHY DIDN'T YOU INDICT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WAS IT A FACTUAL DEFICIENCY OR
OPINION.
THAT IS THE ONLY QUESTION THAT I
THINK IS GOING TO CHANGE ANY
DYNAMIC COMING OUT OF THAT
HEARING.
>> Sean: DON'T WE KNOW THE
ANSWER?
>> WHY DIDN'T YOU INDICT THE
PRESIDENT.
>> Sean: WE KNOW THE ANSWER.
>> WELL, HE'S GIVEN TWO
DIFFERENT ANSWERS.
IDENTIFY THINK HE TOLD BILL
BARR, THERE WAS A FACTUAL
DEFICIENCY.
ALLUDED IN HIS PRESS CONFERENCE
TO THIS D.O.J. O.L.C. OPINION.
IF HE'S GOING TO SAY THAT --
>> Sean: ABOUT FIVE HOURS LATER,
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR AND
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S OFFICE
RELEASED A JOINT STATEMENT KIND
OF MAKING UP FOR THE FACTUAL
ERROR THAT MUELLER MADE, HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT D.O.J. POLICY AND
THE CONSTITUTIONALITY OF WHETHER
YOU CAN OR CANNOT INDICT A
SITTING PRESIDENT.
>> RIGHT.
AND I THINK WHAT THE DEMOCRATS
ARE GOING TO FOCUS ON, IT HAD
THAT POLICY NOT BEEN IN PLACE
WOULD YOU HAVE INDICTED PRIVATE
CITIZEN DONALD TRUMP.
THAT'S THE ONLY THING THAT CAN
COME OUT OF THIS.
>> Sean: DOESN'T HIS ANSWER HAVE
TO BE NO?
BECAUSE OF WHAT HE SAID TO BARR.
>> I THINK IT HAS TO BE NO FOR A
LOT OF REASONS.
I'M SORRY, FIRING JIM COMEY IS
NOT OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
IF IT WERE, ROD ROSENSTEIN WOULD
BE IN TROUBLE, NOT PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
I DON'T, THAT IS THE ONLY --
THAT IS THE QUESTION THAT
CONCERNS ME THE MOST IF I WERE
STILL A REPUBLICAN MEMBER OF THE
HOUSE, WHAT IS GOING TO BE HIS
ANSWER.
WAS IT THE OLC OPINION OR A
FACTUAL DEFICIENCY.
THE REST OF IT, HE'S GOING TO
STICK WITH THE FOUR CORNERS OF
HIS REPORT F YOU'RE A
REPUBLICAN, YOU'RE GOING TO WANT
TO ASK ABOUT BIAS, WHAT YOU
DIDN'T LOOK INTO.
AND I STILL HAVE A BUNCH OF
FRIENDS ON THAT COMMITTEE.
I WOULD SPEND ALL OF MY TIME
GETTING MUELLER TO TALK ABOUT
THINGS HE DIDN'T BOTHER TO LOOK
FOR.
JUST THE FACTUAL PREDICATE FOR
THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
ANYTHING RELATED TO THE FISA
PROCESS.
>> Sean: THE DOSSIER.
>> WHY CHRIS STEELE -- YEAH.
ALL OF THE THINGS HE DIDN'T LOOK
AT.
HE'S GOT AN OUT, I WASN'T ASKED
TO.
BUT I THINK IT'S GOING TO
RESONATE WITH PEOPLE.
THESE ARE IMPORTANT ISSUES.
IF YOU HAVE TIME FOR MEDALLIONS
AND TAXIS WHY DIDN'T YOU HAVE
TIME FOR THIS.
THAT'S A FAIR QUESTION.
TRUST ME WHEN I SAY THIS, SEAN,
WE AREN'T GOING TO LEARN A LOT
UNLESS HE FUMBLES THE ANSWER
FROM MY POINT OF VIEW, THE
REPUBLICAN POINT OF VIEW, IF HE